[Música]
yo soy canadiense que soy que ve que
dice o sea desde que nací vivo o seis
meses de frío de invierno de nieve y
nada y aún así escogí el flamenco para
hacer de eso mi trabajo no mi vida y es
una pregunta que me que me hacía
muchísimo cuando vivía en andalucía pero
tú que eres de allí del frío cómo es que
hace es flamenco por qué porque lo
primero porque ya me esa pregunta me
chocaba mucho porque me parecía mi amor
y mi pasión era tan fuerte que no era
una pregunta para nada no a mí no se me
podía preguntar esto era tan evidente
para mí el hecho de hacer flamenco que
preguntarme eso me parecía muy extraño
pero cuando regresé me quedé como ochoa
en ese en europa cuando regresé me vine
con eddie el codirector de la compañía y
diez de áfrica del norte nació en túnez
entonces verlo a él vivir esto del frío
y me di cuenta de lo que significaba eso
para una persona que es del sur no que
es de un país donde hace calor donde
nunca baja baja de 0 grados y su
reacción no su relación al frío me hizo
pensar ahí pues sí pues claro por eso me
preguntaban y de ahí vinimos con la idea
de que es la identidad no como si el
espacio donde vivimos el ambiente el
entorno cómo influye sobre la identidad
cómo influye sobre mi baile que es
flamenco pero es de aquí totalmente de
aquí y el 'dique es del norte de áfrica
que canta flamenco entonces él viene del
sur vive ahora aquí hay ese choque
en él
[Música]
[Aplausos]
con
[Música]
[Aplausos]
baby viene del teatro entonces él
siempre quiere ir más allá entonces lo
puso al norte del norte en la banquisa y
para él visualmente él también crea la
escenografía entonces él fue en una idea
eso del blanco del norte de ban quizá de
algo muy frío muy vacío muy
y como extraordinario mi imaginario
también porque no vivimos ahí nunca
hemos estado entonces viene mucho de la
imaginación y de lo que hemos podido
leer o ver pues eso fuimos al extremo y
haber hecho que hay que contrastes hay
un contraste que son muy fuertes y que
hablan de por sí yo creo
[Aplausos]
el flamenco es muy bruto es visceral es
una forma de bailar de cantar de tocar
qué es
en blanco y negro es muy muy radical sin
filtro totalmente y veo esto también en
elástico
[Música]